my name is raja baath and I'm the policy
impact coordinator at the American
Friends Service Committee there is
nothing new about what we're doing in
Iraq and Syria now the US has been
bombing Iraq for over 22 years since
1991 and the u.s. engaged against Isis
militarily in 2005 2006 at that time
Isis was called ISI the stomach state in
Iraq so the idea that we can bomb Iraq
into moderation that we can fight
extremism by dropping more bombs doesn't
have any evidence on the ground we have
so much evidence that dropping more
bombs will fuel extremism this happened
in the past and I think it will happen
again now it's a cycle so the fact that
the Iraqi government now is weak and it
always requests foreign intervention to
maintain itself it creates a cycle word
foreign intervention continues and
illegitimate Iraqi political actors
continue for example one of the myths
that we have internationally is that the
Iraqi army is not strong enough because
it needs some more training that's not
the problem
the Iraqi government and the Iraqi
military they're facing a crisis of
legitimacy
there are some really amazing ideas
about diplomatic solutions political
solutions for what's going on in Iraq
and Syria many people inside Iraq and
Syria have been coming up with very
smart ideas that include a political and
social solutions ways to isolate
extremism rather than bomb Iraqis and
Syrians and create the conditions were
extremism thrive unfortunately we can't
really discuss any of these political
and social solutions while the u.s. is
bombing Iraq and Syria
one more download the a j-class mobile
app and join the conversation
available in your App Store now